manger toute la respecte vous pouvez
même y mettre ce que je pense de tous
types de retour de farid ahmad ève
landry pendant sept ans vous avez été
gens dans une taie 9,16 série qui est
sur le point de se terminer à la fin
mars à radio canada comment vous vivez
sur deûle et par étapes franchies le
deuil il se fait vraiment par étapes
parce qu'on on le sentait venir
c'est comme si quelqu'un tombe malade le
petit simon ça s'en vient et fait qu'on
s'y prépare
ont-elles annonce officiellement la
dernière journée le dernier bloc a été
du bonbon à travailler c'est le fun
parce que l' on le savait que c'était
nos derniers moments fait qu'on
profitait de chaque instant avec le réal
avec l'auteur avec chaque technicien on
avait nos petits moments chaque actrice
chaque acteur c'était vraiment le
dernier bloc était jouissif à travailler
tout ce joli petit reposent ici vous
êtes tout jeune et votre coeur fait que
commencer
mais quand même à vous l'impression
d'avoir participé à quelque chose de
gros que vous ne pourrez plus faire
complètement
oui vraiment ai donc dit aussi été on
est découvert juste une fois
moi c'est ce qui m'a mis sa map non
seulement ces basses et sur celui des
choses du théâtre avant mais le grand
public mots connus dans l'unité 9
je veux mourir
il ya deux semaines j'ai rencontré votre
collègue de jeu hubbard couche oui pour
discuter de cette scène de la scène
oui ça a été difficile pour vous son mot
et que ce qu'on pourrait croire en fait
parce que c'est très professionnel c'est
très technique
ce genre de scène le
[Musique]
j'avais pas enlever mes jeans je n'avais
pas à rien faire de tout ça donc c'était
vraiment du jeu et ce moins
c'est ma job fiq c'est gros ce que je
vous dis mais j'aime quand même se met
dans ce genre de situation le il ya
quand même quelque chose là-dedans que
moi ça fait partie de ce haut fait
d'être d'y réfléchir
j'ai vraiment le travail à la maison
c'est 7,5 la gelée mis de côté j'ai
arrêté de réfléchir j'ai fait y'a pas de
texte parfait j'arrête d'y penser
et il y aussi ce qui m'a fait du bien
moi c'est le coréen commentaires que
j'avais eue d'une
victimes d'agressions qui m'avait écrit
personnellement pour me dire ça m'a fait
du bien de voir qu'une fille avec la
confiance de jeunes aient pu recevoir ce
genre d'agression le fait qu a dit ça
fait longtemps que je me sens coupable
puisque j'avais l'impression que c'était
moi qui était faible a dit mais de voir
que ça peut arriver à une jeune bureau
qui est forte
me fait du bien c'est fait comme moi ça
avait été mon petit bond mais tant mieux
si ça au moins 17 personnes n'affecte je
pense que oui c'est nécessaire ça dépend
de la perception top ça dépend d'où tout
acquéreur du style dans un tout autre
registre depuis quatre ans vous jouez le
rôle de lily watts dans sa demie gandhi
mission jeunesse comment adaptez-vous
votre technique de jeu pour parler la
même chose du tout neuf
non mais la technique de jeu j'avoue que
j'ai réfléchi potter parce que je sais
juste d'être dans l'intention pendant la
vérité du moment de la scène c'est mais
cet apprentissage du texte c'est autre
chose parce que comme on s'adresse à des
enfants ya beaucoup d'heureux 10 pts
mais on ne doit pas avoir l'air de se
répéter donc c'est beaucoup la même
chose qu'on dit en différant terme
donc c'est pas prenable c'est vraiment
difficile la pomme dijonnaises ont dit
six fois la même affaire dans un épisode
d'une demi heure mais on le dit de mille
façons différentes fait que les faits ok
ce que j'ai dit le petit pois du grand
roi ou le roi du jeu c'est tellement
mais là oui ça c'est plutôt un peu
quelqu'un au tout début de votre
carrière vous avez fait beaucoup de
théâtre mais beaucoup moins ces
dernières années pourquoi m landry j'ai
eu deux bébés en l'espace de deux ans
donc je dirais qu'il ya eu beaucoup de
ça je trimballe pas de mal être votre
portable pour tout qu'un spot ipad mais
je débarque quand même à mes gars j'en
parlais d'ailleurs justement en fin de
semaine avec une amie actrice puis
elle vit le pire des cas c'est toujours
un petit quelque chose à faire oh je
n'ai pas de théâtre l'année prochaine je
trouvais ça difficile en sainteté avec
mon bébé dans les débuts début d'aller
au théâtre parce que je m'ennuyais
énormément de cette ambiance le je
voyais les productions et j'imaginais
les soirs de premières j'imaginais la
gagne c'est au restaurant après le show
j'imaginais cette ambiance de troubles
ça manque quand on fait pop tu as
vraiment peur de tuer s'applique quand
on ferait pas pendant un certain temps
mais ça vous pensez il aurait pas les
blancs bruit je vous souhaite une bonne
conciliation famille travail
[Rires]